[Music]
school system is a great place to be but
it's nice when you can apply what you
learn and show the world what you can do
kids are some of the most
entrepreneurial people
i know if you experiment you can always
get better that's for
sure we've got atlanta house alain's
been with mover makers and as part of
that we do uh this ig live together
welcome alain so i mean what do you got
how can i help what's on your mind the
one question i think i will talk today
is the idea of how because i'm a teacher
and in some ways i'm an employee and
when we talk about movement makers who
are trying to go and
uh
be of service in the outside than the
idea of entrepreneur but i find it's so
hard to go from a mindset of an employee
to a mindset of an entrepreneur i'm
trying all kind of things and
i pretty much mess everything but
part of the learning
and i was thinking of
some of the stories you may have on when
you were an employee and then i knew
that you did a switch and it was a shift
where you said okay this is what i'm
doing and then i'm sailing forward
so i don't have much experience as an
employee i did not work for a company
for very long before doing my business
and i have to go back to my university
days when when i was an employee so like
being a student not a not not that i was
a teacher or anything um i just remember
i was at a job i was on the team of five
people
and
i get headaches with fluorescent
lighting and um get like blood sugar
issues and so i have to eat uh and
i was bringing food to the office and
they didn't they didn't like it they
didn't like that i was eaten in the
office and i remember i had to have a
a disc man back in the day before mp3
players
and i wasn't allowed to listen to music
any either and it was like super boring
work like copy pasting data entries
super boring stuff and so remember i
would bring music bring my dismay and
put on the floor and run i bought an
extra long um
headphone connection that went from
i put it through my jeans up through my
turtleneck and i'd always wear
turtlenecks every day and then just have
the little thing that popped out here so
i can listen to music while i did this
really boring work and i remember i was
about to get fired i never went to the
lunches i never went out with my
co-workers and they were about to fire
me and then they looked at the results
and i had done more work than the other
four combined on my team like me i did
more work than all four of my other
teammates combined i don't know what
they were doing slacking off and again
it is boring and i just realized that
this is it's too much politics in inside
of a job and just not um
not interesting and like they reward the
wrong things at least the company that i
was at you know but it sounds like a
fairly common experience i think the key
though you know back to the questions is
being in entrepreneurial groups so i
mean movement makers is great to be a
part of right amazing
uh
reading books watching videos like
making it part of the daily routine to
consume some kind of content and then is
there anything you can do at the school
to
like kids are some of the most
entrepreneurial people
i know yes like everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur now
when we were in high school it just
wasn't nobody even knew what the word
entrepreneur meant
um but now everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur so what about even like an
entrepreneur club or an entrepreneur
group or something for the kids so that
it's in your actual
ecosystem as opposed to just uh
when you go home it's funny because if
you uh i think it's last semester
actually instead of having students to
give me a presentation like the usual i
told them i wanted them to create a
website with their and their end
presentation and just tell me about
their website and i know there was an
aspect where there was the content but
just the learning of a website i thought
was they need to do that so that they
can go outside of the school because
school system is a great place to be but
it's nice when you can apply what you
learn and show the world what you can do
like any job us you have some degree of
flexibility and some things where you
can't control you you can't control the
curriculum right like you have to teach
what is government mandated to teach but
there is some degree of flexibility in
what happens after school or even the
examples you're using or
um even rituals in the class or maybe
what's on the wall like maybe you have
entrepreneurial quotes all over the home
room you know that you're in yeah
the assignments are projects or clubs or
after school stuff like there's some i
mean teachers there's so many great
teachers i think also get a really bad
knock like there's
it's more the edgy education system
that's a problem than the teachers that
are the problem like there's so many
great teachers who would like deeply
care about their students and who badly
want them to win and are and they're
frustrated that they can't do more to
help because they're being told what to
do
it's funny because i think it's a
marketing thing i think that a marketing
issue if you think about it we all do
our things in a small classroom that
students are doing their work but often
it's
it's not
projected out where we can just show
other others of the world what we can do
because it's like a portfolio
like for me youtube is a portfolio of
what i can do so and students can learn
doing that as well you don't need to
have a resume on a piece of paper you
can actually show what you have what you
produce
but the content we always talk about
create content and so on that's
something they can do as with as long as
they stay safe and their identity is
protected and so on so that's always
something to keep in mind
yeah i think ev every kid wants to be a
youtuber so when they see
you know when they see their teacher has
a youtube channel even if it's not that
big but even that you're trying and
you're creating yeah it it already forms
a point of connection versus
everybody else
it's funny because i always show them
because i have a
youtube channel for my science class and
i always show them my first because i
have two i have a few channels and the
first one was a minecraft
playing like a play through and it was
just my voice not my face i was scared
of doing all these things then i showed
oh and now i'm doing face-to-face uh
face-to-face videos and then i have a
like a q a session every saturdays
but it's it's like a process of getting
better at it so i always show them the
process so they know that i'm not
they cannot see me as a final product
but they have to see the journey at the
same time and we often forget
i love it dude i love it and and
i i learned from you on a youtube video
i got where is it listen okay let me let
me get it
i like it
you get better when you go outside
yeah so alain
you're not using it right now because i
hear some wind but i forgot i forgot
everything in the car
so alain made this i'm not i'm not much
of a gear guy right but alain made this
video in his car
uh you just pulled over on the side of
the street and you made you know it
wasn't like the most produced video but
he just pulls over
presses recorded in his car and like
that sounds really good
what microphone are you using and then
he sends me he sends me the link and it
was this one and it were you using it
with the with the screen on or just like
just like this
just like this just a little bit then
actually when there's wind it's better
with the puff yeah it just looks like a
beautiful voice like you you're
professional
so i'm learning from the movie makers as
well
there you go always teaching you're
always teaching
it's funny because when you said
like today is like a first to be outside
in in a place like this
uh i have a live like youtube live on
saturday morning so i was here so what
can i do and i decided to ch so i tried
i did experiment with my channel where i
had the live on youtube
by uh
by uh it's a power play i said well
let's try something out of the blue and
i tried several ways of doing the videos
so i could learn okay what sounds better
how can i use my phone because i don't
have all the gears in the world so so i
have some some positive four views i'm
happy of those four views and but it's
going well i can see if you experiment
you can always get better that's for
sure
yeah and and i love that you're willing
to try you know i think a lot of people
just get the idea but they never do
anything with it where you are always
willing to go off and try it's back to
the mindset thing you know anytime you
want to shift the mindset it's it's
really much more functional environment
than anything else the fastest way to
shift the mindset is be around the
people who think the way you want to
think and so yeah for for people who are
an employee you have your at-home
rituals and then you have your your
rituals at at work and the good news is
i think like kids today are so
entrepreneurial
minded already
like they're going to be more
entrepreneurial than than you might be
just in in their mindset in their way of
thinking how do you encourage that how
can you be a part of that how can you if
it's sharing your entrepreneurial dreams
or is there is there ways to bring that
into the content inside the teaching
where they're doing research on
entrepreneurial companies i mean a lot
of teachers use my videos in their
classes and they use my books in their
classes
um
it's like i mean i never expected it but
it ended up becoming an amazing little
tradition there's one teacher who's got
a grade six a grade seven class in every
every year they go through your one word
together and then they tweet at me and
they share what their one words were
like i never intended the book to be
designed for grade six grade seven
students but it's cool to see it being
used that way it is good actually the i
was teaching virtually for two years so
i'm going back to school so
that's that's one of my idea to try to
get the class out of your book so we can
because the one word is so important and
even though it changes at least they can
focus on what they want and how what
feels great for them
well if you do it let me know we'll get
we'll get some maybe get some signed
copies out to them or we'll do like a
zoom afterwards for the students or
whatever what what um what age group are
you working with
the grade nine intense so that's 13 14.
um but every so often i have a grade 12
class and they always have great
questions and because
they're going from a high school life to
maybe like post-secondary or sometimes
the workforce and
and sometimes just having a vision of
where
where they can go or where to focus
their thoughts there's so many options
out there i feel bad sometimes for them
because for me there were fewer options
not for them it's the sky's the limit
when you think about it
so they're like
they're lucky to have a teacher like you
man who cares and wants to see them win
that's what we need to do and and also
to build confidence because it's
interesting because as i try to build
their confidence they help me as well
because they have ideas that i've never
thought of
like perspective and so on and that's
why we need to listen to teenagers more
often often we forget if we say well we
tell them what to do but they have
they have a wealth of uh perspective
that is amazing
i agree that's why i listen to you and i
bought the microphone
i know
and uh
let's see what is the other one um i
know that the reason why i want to play
outside is uh i used to be a geologist
and i do try to play outside a bit more
and i try to tell people around me and
students that
insight is great because we're protected
between our four walls but as soon as
you go out there you need to trust
yourself a little bit more and there's
so much more you can actually accomplish
if you just give it a try
and it's a confidence matter and a
mindset as you mentioned earlier
i don't know how or why he did this but
i remember i had a history teacher in
high school grade 12 history who uh
would often take us outside for the
class like it was a really nice day he's
like hey i got your books we're going
outside and we just sit on the grass
under the under a tree and we would
teach he would teach the class outside
on the ground um not when we had a test
or anything but just like a lecture it's
like that was that was really fun it was
different like what what are we doing
why are we not in the classroom but
yeah just just getting outside and
getting on nature i don't know it uh
made it a lot more memorable that's for
sure actually i have a story for you i i
teach science and there's always a unit
on ecosystems and by the school there's
a little creek and i always used to go
there
just with the class so we can we can go
in the puddle and and boys and girls
would just go and step in the water it
was just this much water but just did
get back in the class all dirty but they
were hot so there was a time when the
board said for safety we cannot be too
close to the water and and the path was
close to the
close to the uh this creek and then with
my class we figured that we could all
bring all those uh
uh let's see all uh
you know when you go into a boat like
safety jackets and those bananas
so i went to the saying we need to lend
up floaters and a safety jacket just to
make sure the board is happy and he says
no no don't go out with the school with
banana floaters because we all look bad
and he says it's just a bit silly but
but the students were all excited just
to go outside and play but we still do
and
the uh
two years ago we did the
earthworm hunt to try to see how
the population of earthworms but just
just play with the dirt people often
inside you play with their books you're
on the desk and they forget that you
have to play a bit
so what did you do today to play evan
besides uh
live
i i i've been so i'm talking my team all
day but i just took a break at [ __ ]
before this i had 25 minutes and i was
out uh on the grass with my with my mini
dash wound out in the backyard
uh looking at
my emails and what i had coming up but
just it's a it's a beautiful day here in
toronto it's like let's get some sun
yeah that's perfect since moving to a
house out of the condo we've been doing
a lot more grounding a lot more time
outside backyard campfires
you know barefoot on the grass
it's um
very different than the condo living
i bet i need to check the two new videos
because i haven't i don't remember
seeing your new recording videos i know
you were painting and i need to see how
it looks like so
that's my my next thing in the coming
week coming week i don't know if i even
have any new videos of this place
okay that's maybe
the only the listen alan like we just
moved right so the only thing that's set
up
is is that look the office is set up
because that's the first thing i have to
do right so you can kind of see
oh i see the office nice so that's set
up but everything else is just empty
[Laughter]
you're still moving in okay
yeah i don't know it's like it's
completely it's completely unbelievable
amazing this is kind of set up i don't
know what this is going to become
but it's all it's all it's all empty you
know like the path outside is all empty
it's just we're still sleeping on the
floor you know we ordered a bed that
comes in four weeks or something so
the only thing that that is remotely set
up is just
the office because i gotta film content
that's true yeah but the content that's
nice so i have i have not uh filmed
anything kind of showing
the house or anything yet so if you go
looking for it you won't find anything
what i just did is probably the most i
filmed so there you go you got the tour
it's a good project
it's a big project it's a big project
are you going out of the city in the in
the summer
like i just left for quebec city for a
couple days and uh and you are you going
anywhere with the world opening up it's
been crazy like everybody wants me to go
and speak at different things and i
don't want to spend
you know 50 out of 52 weeks on the road
so i'm picking one thing per month to go
to and toronto is so beautiful in the
summer that i like i'd rather go away in
february than
miss out on all the greatness that's
here
oh that makes sense actually the in the
coming
the coming weeks and because it's the
summer i hope to do a
youtube live at the the rom that's one
of my my goal and i want to do youtube
live at the ago just to just to have a
background different um and i'm trying
to see i'm trying to get up to get a
small whiteboard
like maybe 30 centimeters by
45 so i can carry it around so i can if
i have to do some science i can do some
notes for uh for the youtube live so i
think that'll be nice that's it i love
that i mean but the entire world of
science
exactly i know
and i think i think i needed that i
needed the world to open up a little bit
and
it's nice because otherwise we're inside
you're doing great videos inside but for
science when you kind of touch and apply
it it's always i find it's more fun i
mean just around you is a thousand
different science videos if you want to
explain
physics or geometry or i mean it's all
it's all there
a little i i like the little uh
the little pocket uh
white board and you do a little mini
lesson
a little mini science lesson as you go
yep and that and that's a beauty i know
that i always have a few people watching
my lives all the time and always bring
questions and it makes it nice why are
you doing youtube live though
that's a good question there's a few
reasons first i like to be able to
answer questions for people that have
them so it's a bit like the teacher live
thing
second i find it's less work for editing
the video if i do it live and sometimes
i don't always have time to edit them
and
and third
sometimes i was running out of ideas and
i said well let's get people to give me
ideas and that idea is from you evan
people say oh i look at comments of
people and answer questions and i
thought it would be nice um so and
that's once a week on saturday morning i
already have 1600 subs i'm a few
thousand away
like a thousand fold smaller than you
but it's going there slowly
and uh but it's good this summer i want
to do more videos and content and so on
so
i love it dude i love it and if you need
the interaction it's great the only
thing with the youtube live is once the
live is done youtube doesn't promote it
anymore like if you ever go to a search
page or you look at suggested or the
home page you may see it when it's live
but afterwards you'll never see a live
broadcast almost never see a live
broadcast youtube really destroys lives
in their algorithm after it's done
okay
so a strategy to go live is you could go
live and then unlisted afterwards
and then download it
and edit a second of it and then put it
up as a regular video or just edit out
the beginning
like a quick edit of just deleting are
we live i mean i don't know how you
start like
is this working in the shaky you know um
and then put that up as a video because
the lessons you're teaching are still
relevant in three months and six months
in a year
so and that's something i have to look
into for uh maybe having an editor
because i usually i try to do live
between 30 and 60 minutes okay and i
have several subjects so because i can
have chapters in the videos
because i've done that so sometimes i go
through stream stream yard and download
the video then i upload it and use
chapters so i hope that the search will
go well
but i think i would like to see if i can
take that those long one-hour videos and
cut it down in shorter sections
for uh for instagram for example if i
want to do that or just have shorts on
youtube these uh these are things i need
to look into so yeah you could i did
if you're not going to do it yourself
then once you add complexity of having
somebody else whether that's somebody
you hire or like a formal student that
you really liked or whatever um
but the next like the easy momentum step
is you're already making the videos
once a week going live you have more
plans coming up which is great like i
love the the street science yeah that's
it it's street science atlanta street
science you go and you explain
something but and it'd be a shame if you
make those videos and then they never
get any views because youtube then kills
the the the um the views on them so
uh even just that like go live and then
put it to unlisted afterwards
and then just edit the first two seconds
out or eight seconds or whatever
whatever the the junk is at the
beginning as you're getting ready and
then upload it again just as a as a
regular video without editing chapters
and all the other stuff just to have it
better for long term yeah okay that
makes sense okay thank you for the input
there and it doesn't mean you can't then
go hire an editor and do the rest of
later right cool but what what often
happens is oh i don't have an editor so
then i can't do it
and then nothing happens
yeah
no the uh i was talking there's a few
people that have been following me and
i started in june last year so i have uh
have a youtube live that i've either
lived or i've re-uploaded the video so
it's been at least 52 weeks
so i'm proud it's the momentum the idea
of momentum i'm doing it once a week and
so it's very nice
i love it man i love it
well it's great to see you great to see
the smile thank you for bringing you're
kind of bringing the street science
already to us showing us very nice the
the beautiful i'm i'm jealous i love it
and views here so
so you don't have to travel very far you
just have to do ig live with people and
you're traveling at the same time
i love it ella thank you for your
positivity and and love and always
appreciate you man and we'll talk to you
soon
thank you evan and take care all
movement makers take care bye-bye enjoy
your trip cheers man
there she is hey hey how's it going
how's it going how are you jen i'm great
i'm great it's hot down here in florida
i'll tell you that much i like it well
i'm in canada and it is it is not so hot
we had a couple of days of hot and now
it's now it's just it's still hoody
weather outside oh my gosh nope i think
i wear a hoodie like maybe twice a year
down here i'm down in west palm so it
doesn't get like that ever
i love it well well uh jamie jen's been
with movement makers for a while and
we're doing uh a fun ig live together as
a thank you so
what do you got how can i help what's on
your mind well um i just would love to
talk to you a little bit about like you
know how to get the youtube following
going um
last year i had um my account with
facebook was hacked and i got deleted
and facebook was like my main platform
and i had about 40 000 followers and i
was like on the upswing of really doing
some good things and when that got
deleted i fought with facebook back and
forth for like seven months never got my
account back and so um the good thing is
because there's always like you know
something good that comes from any you
know anything um is that it really
encouraged me to branch out into other
platforms and to you know ig and uh i
groaned but i did a tick tock and then i
had a video go viral and now i have a
decent following there and then youtube
and linkedin and um and i'm a one-man
show so i'm kind of doing everything
myself so um i'm not quite sure where to
begin i'll tell you a little bit about
what i do um i have kind of a unique
business uh which
if you can help me brand this i will you
know
let's make that our goal that's our goal
yeah exactly exactly so um i do what is
called equine assisted empowerment so i
have six horses
four of which i think um personality
profiling if you've ever taken like a
disc or myers-briggs or something like
that and four of my horses are one of
each of the major personality profiles
so if you believe it or not horses have
personalities just like we do when we
call it the pony personas you can go to
my website take a quick take and take my
quiz and figure out which worst it is um
my bet on you is that you are a dante so
um each one yes so and we kind of what
did you start with equine assistance was
it's assisted empowerment so think tony
robbins with horses
yeah
empowerment just getting just getting
the words down okay yeah yeah yeah so
it's it's and i actually met you through
uh your live with ray higdon that you
did a while back okay and um ray's had
his team at my place and then they've
done my a lot of my experiences that so
i do basically like corporate team
building empowerment my my um
my primary markets women and my
secondary market is um corporations
business i just recently did a live
um training virtually for a team out in
california that works for facebook
so um so things like that so that that's
really kind of what i do it's it's kind
of a challenge to explain it's like it's
like can you imagine the person that
invented gum
you know if you invented gum like how do
you tell people like what it is and how
it didn't have flavor back then it was
just this resin look you eat it no you
don't eat it you just chew it well does
it taste good well no
well does it have good you know is it
that nutrition well no you just what the
hell so that's kind of where i'm at like
how do you brand something that is is
challenging for people to understand so
what are people coming to to the to the
to your center four
so most of my everything that we do now
is virtual since covered so they're
coming here to understand who they are
like the one of the most powerful
questions you'll ever ask yourself is
who am i and to determine what that
looks like
through a 1200 pound animal is a
completely unique experience and then um
and then to have the opportunity to come
here for you know on site um as i get
more established with my facility down
here because i just moved to voice bomb
from orlando so
i have uh virtual courses
and i do masterminds
okay so when you say i'm a let's role
play with me then so i get a better
sense so i'm a dante
i would bet money on it all right what
what does that mean what what how how am
i enlightened now that i know that i'm a
dante oh my gosh because you're
you know just describe the
characteristics of somebody that you
would meet like you know having a
conversation with them you know you're
decisive you're solutions driven you're
about taking action you're bold um
you're charismatic you know you're
you're either arrogant or affable you're
effusive you're probably a little bit
mischievous
so you know you don't you're not afraid
to get into a little bit of trouble you
know and um you you actually you know
you're out there to change the world
you're out there to do something big
only about 10 of the population are
actually true dante's think uh steve
jobs is dante and and uh tony robbins is
a dante he's like this giant 1200 pound
fiery red
massive presence kind of character and
he's just larger than life and um
and knows and isn't afraid to take
action to do things am i close
well i mean those are great those are
great characteristics i i have to live
up to being the dante i guess um
what time
ray incidentally is a trace who is uh
like like dante is the steve wozniak rs
steve jobs traces the steve wozniak you
know
and you have you have um trace
characteristics as well and he is uh
this white unicorn type of horse he is
he's white with blue eyes he's
completely unique um
a little bit more introverted a little
bit more of an observer so again you
have these characteristics as well
analytical you're dependable reliable
you um are trustworthy you're kind of an
old soul you like to get things done you
like to put the period at the end of
sentences you know something you know
things like that and and you do your
best work when you're creatively
inspired so and then you can even go
into like carl young's the archetypes so
like dante's my warrior trace is my
magician uh maverick who is a racehorse
that won more money than sea biscuit and
got rescued and ended up at my at my all
my horses are rescues
do you know seabiscus my favorite movie
of all time what i yes i did not know
that but now i do i've seen that movie
like 30 times oh so now it's a pretty
good movie he's and he's the opposite of
you he's he's your um
your king or queen like he's this
represents the sovereign he's calm he's
quiet he's reserved he's he's
regal you know and he takes care of the
whole herd kind of behind the scenes uh
brene brown is a maverick
okay so these these are your
like dante trace these are your you came
up with these yes
okay perfect so these are my four horses
that i that i have rescued and you know
dante trace maverick and bella i'm a
bella
okay so so are people coming to you is
it basically like taking a personality
test but it's exactly like that i have
you go take my quiz so you can go to my
website and that's the starting point
like that that's kind of the start of
the funnel
so um i you know
again i'm doing this on myself if
anybody that loves horses wants to come
and help me with my social media i need
help i'm drowning and so much to do
because people really need this right
now people need to understand like how
to stand in their truth how to have this
journey for themselves and we take them
down this this incredible experience
through horses to understand that
and um with the ultimate mission to say
can save horses and change lives
okay so then what's the connection that
by
a certain percentage of your profits go
to supporting more horses or or yeah
right well it's i think of did you ever
had an impossible burger
you ever ever heard yeah the vegetarian
one yeah yeah right so the and beyond
meat and impossible burger were both
invented by to the same gentleman named
pat brown so pat brown number one that
the impossible burger actually wanted to
subvert climate change by encouraging
people that were on the fence between
eating meat or eating
a vegetarian option at least something
that didn't taste like you know that
that tasted good he knew he wasn't going
to get the backyard kansas city barbecue
or to get to go vegan but he could maybe
have an option to so that was that was
his thing but his whole goal wasn't to
make a veggie a veggie burger his whole
goal was to subvert climate change
so
how do you do that you can't you know
again you're not just going to get
people to stop eating meat you got to
give them a quality option so he took a
subversive approach to a socially
conscious problem and that's exactly the
same thing i'm doing because again what
do you think of when you think of a
horse you think of you know their speed
you think of the tiki derby sea biscuit
you know um the budweiser clydesdale you
think of their that their physical
capability but what we're doing is we're
healing people
we are i'm do i'm working with
post-traumatic stress disorder victims
i'm working with veterans i'm working
with women from abuse but it doesn't
have to be like that
and it can be like i said you know right
you know people bring their teams here
for um you know touted why does susie in
accounting hate doug and marketing well
if we understand that susie is a
maverick and you know it's just team
building right team building with horses
understanding yourself through horses
all with the mission of showing the
world because only one out of 11 people
own a horse
showing the world the power that horses
can have outside of their physical
ability outside of their ability to run
faster jump high
and so when we take that subversive
approach we might get
we might move the needle a little bit on
the tens of thousands of horses that get
shipped out of this country to slaughter
every year for human consumption that's
not okay with me
so human consumption wow okay
yes
why not just go more direct like horses
why not create a a um and i'm just
playing with you here like we're
brainstorming as opposed to going down
the personality test route
why not create a place for people to
heal with horses
i have that
that yes
right now all of my programs are virtual
because i do not have a facility
but um that i can host people on site
and hosting people on site is tricky
because people bring their garbage
will bring their garbage and i don't
want everybody's garbage being dumped on
my horses so anytime that anybody comes
to on site and having an interaction on
site with my horses that's going to be
like the next level like you need to you
need to have the information you need to
know some of the things virtually before
you show up
um and then when you can that's like
that's not the first step in the funnel
if that makes any sense yeah but then
it's fine but so there's a process but
yeah it doesn't but why not make the
business healing with horses
well that's what it is kind of but like
what what it comes off as at least in
the initial description is yeah it's
a personality test to help you develop
self-awareness through the lens of my
four horses as opposed to
no we're like we're going to help you
heal because i mean horses are mad i
don't tell you how magical horses are um
but
if the business is not about like it
feels almost like a gimmick
that okay here's the person and
it's not meant to offend you you're not
going to if it's if it's like if the
real thing is i want to heal people
through my horses or through horses in
general
and
and that leads to saving more horses
around the world as well and that leads
to like you have your center now four
but maybe that becomes a hundred horses
and maybe you open up centers and i
don't know i don't know what states
allow you know i wanted
my vision is huge so yeah and and all
you need is four you don't need 400 but
four can feed 400
you know just by having a program with
four trained horses to to offer this
you know and branding my four but i i
get i hear your point
so
it's like a it's like a retreat you can
have you can have a retreat experience
yep right that's how i started and so
coveted i was doing i was i was only
live i didn't have any virtual any
virtual programs at all okay but things
are opening up things are back yes uh
and and florida's florida's been open
for
ever it never closed
so you're good i'm in canada we've the
the most restrictive
you know laws and stuff but again right
now right now i don't have an on-site
facility
that i can host people go
um partner with somebody who does
mm-hmm i did that last summer i i'd
how do what i really want to do because
i don't have the reach
that i would have
with a virtual program i really want to
get my the virtual programs so i can
have more reach
and people can then use my virtual
programs and have their horses in canada
and i don't have to be there if they
come and experience my my virtual
programs then they can go to a facility
in canada
and experience it there with any horses
that are trained with my methods
so you have a couple options i mean
at the at the i think at the end of the
day
what we need to get across is people are
healing through the horses correct
it's not about the personality test to
know that your extrovert introvert dante
whatever it's like you you can heal
your wounds your trauma
and become more whole by
following this process
to being with horses so then it becomes
is there any
micro healing that can be done
through
through through an instagram live
through a zoom through a virtual like
hand that can if i can't actually touch
the horse but dante's coming up and you
know snorts into the camera or something
like can i still
that's
micro heal right so
instead of thinking like just about
reach i i get it
but it's more about like can we give can
we help people can we heal people the
business is healing people right
initially when you said i'm thinking of
branding my horses and you're going a
brand new business and you're going
through um
uh
personality i was thinking like
horsepower like you should horsepower
just makes a lot of sense but but
healing with horses
that's the brand yeah
dealing with horses is the brand yes
healing with horses so everything that
we do now is about how do we heal people
with our horses
okay and
i don't know what an online experience
looks like and and that's like how do
you how can you create something that is
authentic that like yes people are
getting an experience and you feel
um
is true
you know like it's not just
it's not just a pony show
right we're not just like bringing some
horses out and say hey you're here like
it actually how can we create an online
experience that will be actually healing
for people not as much as actually being
able to touch dante or ry dante or hang
out with dante but still there's
something in there um
i don't know what that program looks
like but it but that's that's the
program where you're taking people's
trauma and issues and where they've been
burned and we're helping them heal
yes
that the programs are created okay
that's done like i have um a one hour
free thing i do every week
i have um i go live pretty much every
day with some kind of something
um and i have like you know a five-day
challenge that i do once a month that's
like i go
for the first four days i go through
each one of the horses and help you
understand
you know why bella is codependent why
maverick needs trust why you know trace
needs motivation and you know why dante
needs engagement
and like what each personality needs to
go through the healing process and then
on the last day um i i give some
addition you know i give some bonus
materials and then i go through my stack
is the healing more dependent on the
personality type or the type of trauma
that they've been through
the personality types believe it or not
okay the the type of trauma's trauma man
doesn't really matter what kind it is
i really want to be clear too because
this isn't just about trauma this is um
because you know there's two types of
people that go to for any kind of
personal development experience
um it's the people that want to heal and
that have a gap in their life they want
to close and the people that want to go
to the next level
so you know you have those those two
types and um i i want to i do want to
cater to both
but i don't only want to cater to the
people that are suffering from trauma
because i mean it we all need healing
because healing is not just healing a
wound healing is transcending where we
are in my opinion
so that's really what it's about and
understanding
um who you are will help you understand
how to heal because you don't it's it's
totally dependent on the personalities
you
dante's gonna heal
by going out and you know
chopping down trees or going to
kickboxing or something where maverick's
going to heal by reading a book or
meditating right and there's just
different everybody has their different
ways of of processing stuff and
understanding who you are will
understand how you need to heal and
that's what i teach how do we how do we
turn it into a healing experience
beyond just the
like dante represents something
he represents a personality type but
like if dante wasn't a horse and and you
just had your four personality types yep
and you go tell them okay go chop down
trees or go hit your next mission or go
you know whatever it is
how do you
how do you actually
start the healing process with the horse
live together
instead of telling me to go read the
book or something i take um i i i tell
stories i take them through a metaphor
i'll take them through like i i'll have
um i'll have like a two a couple of
cones and i'll do like a figure eight
with the horse
and and i'll have him and then like a
jump and i'll have him jump and jump so
i'll have him do two very and all four
horses i'll have him do like the same
task
but i show people how they show up
differently
everybody's doing the exact same task
but they're all doing it differently and
as their me as their leader or as their
healing facilitator on there to
show like you should see this i mean
it's incredible it really is and it's
it's so hard to explain because so bella
will be out there and she's like zooming
around the figure eights and she has to
like she feels like she needs to over
achieve all the time and she's a pleaser
and she's codependent she second guesses
herself
and so being able to be empowered and to
slow down
and get focused and understand that
simple things done well
is actually how it's going to bring you
more centered so i take them through the
process and they watch bella they watch
her ear change they watch her body
language change they watch her breathing
change and go from whatever she's doing
where she's a little bit concerned to oh
it's just a figure eight
and then i'll get trace out or dante out
trace for instance because he's the
opposite of her i'll take him through
the figure eight and i'll say trace
just trotting
slow like the chain gang just watching
him go oh we're doing this again
and then showing what i can do as his
leader as his mentor as his facilitator
to get him to be inspired about doing
the exact same task he thought was
boring 30 seconds ago and how that can
get him more centered
and then i can take dante and say okay
stop trying to turn the figure eight
into something else and make your own
game out of it because if you aren't
ready for a dante
dante's are always ready for you
they're always ready they always have an
answer and you gotta be one step ahead
of the dantes
and then the same thing with mavericks
same exact exercise doing the demos with
mavericks are really hard because all
maverick mavericks need time
and patience and need to learn how to
build trust and so i'll do the exact
same exercise with each horse and show
very different uh tactics and very
different ways to allow them to become
their true centered self in like a 30
minute demo
so then how can we take the demo
to an experience
and like the easiest one to be like hey
they're they're on the horse but that
doesn't scale
because you're gonna do four at a time
and and there's you
but so what could we do
so that it's an experience of people so
they're not just watching it happen and
you're talking about it because somebody
a horse walks out they don't know what
horses is but if they've gone through it
like oh that's dante i'm a dante and
they can see it happen okay
i can see it but how do i feel it
maybe it's
like are we doing a group
meditation session and we're all
touching dante or are we like what can
we actually do together do we go for do
all the dantes go for a 7 a.m hike
together and we're walking we take turns
like holding dante or that's that's the
easy part when you're talking on site
like
if you come to
come down i'll do if you're ever next
time you're in west palm beach come and
experience it my gift
my gift to you because you'll it's magic
you that is not the hard part
the tripping block that i need to help
with is um
how to make it a virtual experience you
know because people are like people will
be on and like when i presented i
presented for about 30 people and i
represented for rank makers live a
couple you know a couple years ago etc
like that's the experience and what i
what i had to do when covet hit was i
still had to feed six horses and take
care of 10 acres and you know i still
had all of my overhead so i had to take
that on-site experience and put it in a
virtual format and i did it
and it's incredible and people are on
from all over the world that people from
dubai and australia and canada and
they're all watching this all at the
same time and i did it live
and it was blowing people's minds
because they were like i never thought i
could have an experience like this with
a horse virtually that would totally
change my life one gal
quit her job the next day and started
her own accounting firm you know i mean
the results are mind and then started
doing this feminine movement dance thing
totally changed your life changed her
relationship with her husband changed
her business changed everything from
this five-day
um this course that i did that now i now
run as a six-week mastermind
so um
the marketing i like like see like even
here in this conversation where i keep
coming back i'm like no
come on i got
i'm not doing on site right now that's
virtual
that because i really want to be able to
have more impact with more people i
would have never had the impact the
woman that did um from facebook wrote me
after and said that they did their
entire team did a huge trust building
exercise after my course and she's she's
actually flying out to visit me after
doing my course for an hour
you know and it was it was virtual and
so once people dip their toe into this
pool they they could care less if it's
horses or dogs or squirrels they're like
this is impactful because what you see
isn't a color or an
infj or you know a thing it's an animal
like to your point how did you feel what
did what do you experience on the 31st
time you watched sea biscuit you've seen
it a million times but that movie makes
you feel a certain way so does this and
it allows you to create
in your mind a visual and experiential
um idea of who like how to deal with the
dantes of the world that are kind of
pushing your num you know pushing your
buttons the traces of the world that you
can't get off the couch how to
understand who you are
so how do i get that message out to
people in a way where they want to you
know they want to convert they want to
you know that i want to get conversions
does that make sense yeah i don't want
to do the on-site at the moment not
right now
but so you've got options like in terms
of the branding i would call it heal
heal with horses or healing with horses
it's different it's unique it stands out
especially if you're going after a
business world you're going to rank
masters or other conferences like we're
going to do what with horses like it's
different yes uh the personality stuff i
would not lead with
okay
it might be how you get there
right like once they're in they don't
know how they're gonna heal with horses
then then we're following jen's
methodology right and and part one of
the and like hey okay we can't overwhelm
the horses so we're gonna do x you have
to know you're a dante before you go in
and hang with dante or whatever whatever
your four steps or eight steps or ten
steps or your steps yes but but people
don't care about the steps no
they want that the healing with the
horses that's what we've been promised
how do we heal with horses okay
anybody who you've done anything with
you try to turn it into an annual thing
so
um if you don't if you did rank masters
in your life do cool how do i speak at
the next event how do i speak like you
speak at every rank masters going
forward
if you've done something with facebook
cool how do we turn this into an annual
thing got it so that every year or every
quarter we come in and we help like
facebook is such a big company that they
could if they loved you they can enter
you to other departments but you have to
ask for it right they have a great time
like hey is there anybody in
another department oh yeah
i might be a good friend of this like
three days ago so and she was blown away
blown away
so so while she's still feeling
the energy
before she moves on to
all the other things that are she's
dealing with in her life right yes
i messaged her right before i got on
here so i'm on it
that's
yeah i'm on it man so okay so with her
team it's like with her with her who's
making who's the decision maker for her
group
how can you come in
every quarter or every year
and do it again because there's new
people who come in all the time there's
new team members who come in all the
time there's new issues that pop up all
the time and even if they had you in six
months ago it doesn't mean oh now they
got it and they don't need any
reinforcement or training ever again
right
so so everybody that you've done
something with
now we create an annual program with
them it's not a one and done thing it's
an ongoing thing
one to many i think is really where i'm
going to have more impact too
well not necessarily
you know like i think the ability to
hang with the horses
actually be there is
magical yes and the way to scale that is
not necessarily you having a thousand
locations across america but you could
train the trainer on how to do it yes
and i have a program like that's already
established all of my programs are
established it's right now just people
don't know what it is you know and they
don't know what it they don't know what
it does
well they're going to heal
like the mechanics of how it works
doesn't matter nobody cares
right okay like it's the top line i'm
going to teach you to heal with horses
and we can do it in person or we can do
it as an online event
and especially if you're bringing it to
the business community where
most of the people you know most people
in the equine business you know they're
a lot more artists than they are
entrepreneur yeah oh my god i
don't
well but that's the advantage because
but anybody who anybody who raises
horses or is in the equine business
would would talk about how magical and
majestical horses are and how healing
they can be to people and the like
connection they have the people
everybody the vibe that you're putting
out around the horses everybody in the
horse industry would express something
similar they may not agree with like
personality types but most people
wouldn't say like horses are not magical
if you're in the equine business right
but the ability to turn that into a a
service that could help
businesses
corporations
nobody knows how to do that
so this is now where you're
standing out and unique and different
yes
so we call it healing with horses
everybody has all of their team building
you know
there's all that
every business every major corporation
does some sort of team building where
you know right but not with horses no
i'm the only person in the world doing
what i'm doing and everybody has
personality type stuff that you don't
want to be in that business we're not in
that business we're in the healing with
horses business
how is that going to how is healing with
horses going to translate into
um
like breaking into to corporations
well how do how do you help people like
not what's the result of people
they got they
they got found me through because the
title is leadership with horses
how to be a better leader through
horsemanship this is you are talking my
age-old argument with me and um my
assistant we've gone back and forth
between should it be leadership and like
tony robbins or should it be healing and
more like deepak chopra
because it's both it really is truly
both because you become empowered
through the horses and you heal through
the horses and how you become empowered
is how you heal but you can't you can't
lead with that to you know a corporation
that's having trouble with inner
department conflict you know what i mean
like that's a tough sell
what's the problem with the the conflict
the communication
or
you know they're just not doing their
job it's more surface you know you start
talking about healing for businesses
you know they they're like
i don't know
individuals that's i think that but i
don't know i could be wrong but my in my
my experience in the past is that from a
business perspective they want
leadership from an individual
perspective they want healing
so you have heal with horses as your
main website
and then if you know you're dealing with
a corporate you can talk about the
leadership benefits of it as simple as
that okay you you're not you're you're
having we're have we've had this
conversation so many times oh my god
it's
it's like which way do we go the way
you're gonna get most of the business
anyway is gonna like it's service-based
business so the way you get most of the
business is not nobody's searching for
leadership with horses or
like healing events with what like
people are not so we're not winning the
seo
which games fine to your point about
like we're selling gum people don't know
what it is so
you're gonna get word of mouth referrals
which is why we need to talk to
everybody who's experienced it
create annual programs with them not
just let it because you could it could
have been great but they may not be
thinking come in again
right like you need to reinforce this we
need to do this every every year every
quarter
and and then giving them the tools to
talk about it absolutely amazing then
and that's i think that's to your point
you know getting getting on people's
annual rosters is brilliant that's
that's not something
i really thought about i thought about
like hitting the businesses and getting
like corporate stuff you know once a
quarter once every six months but i
never thought about doing like summits
and you know i i definitely want to
thank one of my goals is to present with
you know grant cardone and you know
people like yourself that know people
that know people because this is it's
powerful i mean i've spoken on stage at
tony robbins i've done a ted talk i'm
getting ready to be published my book's
coming out next month you know so
there's a lot happening um you know for
me and i've been busting my ass for
seven years and actually 18 years with
horses so
it's it's been a tough road um i started
out but listen anytime anytime you're
doing a speaking gig or you get a
corporate gig
you default to saying okay we should do
this again in a quarter yeah absolutely
let's create an annual program you have
an amazing experience while they're
still there because then they're going
to go back to their daily life and get
destroyed again so while they're still
in the energy and the vibe they've got
the horsepower with them
uh let's figure out an annual program to
keep this energy going yeah because they
need to recharge their batteries and
come back
in corporate the other the other huge
win for you is that people will switch
companies and switch
jobs if you're in touch with not just
the person at facebook but if you stay
in touch with the members who are
actually through it yes and then one of
them leaves somebody's leaving next next
month and they're going to google and
they're going to
they're going to tick-tock and they're
going to other companies that's
brilliant if you're in touch with them
now now you have a google program now
you have a tick tock program and now you
have an airbnb program really yeah and
that's that's how facebook found me is
that i have my experience on airbnb
so
it's that's really you know the way they
found me they booked me through airbnb
so the language that you use to talk
about it at the top is the healing with
horses but then tell me the benefits i'm
gonna get out of it you're gonna learn
how to be a better leader for yourself
and for your team you're going to learn
how to improve your communication skills
you're going to learn boom boom boom
boom like all through the power of
horses
and the personality stuff doesn't matter
like it it matters to your process
but it's not a selling prop
to get people to come in i'm not coming
because i need to know if i'm a dante or
i'm a tracer or whatever right
and it also puts you into a world of
myers-briggs and all the other companies
that now we have to like why is yours
better than myers-briggs we already paid
for myers-briggs why do i care about the
four horse
you know uh
ideas like that you you still do it
because it's important because
people will heal differently but it's
not in the not in the presentation
because i don't care about the how i
care about what i'm going to get out of
it of course and what i get out of it is
i'm going to be a better leader i'm
going to be more self-aware i'm going to
heal my wounds i'm going to
be a better communicator i'm going to
like whatever the things are that you
actually will help people with
that's the pitch
okay keem with horses
it's a three-day in in-person experience
or three-hour online experience or
whatever it is where you will learn how
to boom boom boom boom boom all through
the power of amazing horses that's [ __ ]
and now you should feel that like what
are those point forms of what are the
things you actually get be a better
leader improve your communication skills
heal from you right now whatever it is
about what it is for sure what what it
what is that what do you say what it
what it does not what it is
like what do i get how do i how am i
better human
yeah how am i a better human as a result
of this like if i'm going to if i'm
going to you know if i'm going to a
doctor i'm going to have a surgery what
do i care care about not having
cancer
exactly but that's what you're talking
about like so here's the anesthesia
we're going to use and here's a scalpel
we're going to use and here's like like
who cares all i care about is the cancer
guard by the end of this thing right
that's what they care about
so but it's still important to have the
right scalp on right anesthesia and
right so like you still follow the
process that's just not the market
that's not great marketing
telling me that
the dante or trace or whatever because
it's the process that people don't care
about right right well i'm a creator i
you know i'm a i'm a generator i'm i'm
definitely not a marketer but well but
this is this this is that and it's just
simple tweaks like that because if
you're gonna say if you have on your
website
that okay you'll heal with horses
and you switch it from
figure out what your personality your
horse personality type is and if you're
a dante or whatever else which won't
make sense of people but then if you say
well i'm going to teach you how to be a
better communicator and be a better
leader and be a xyz those little tweaks
make a huge difference for people to say
yes or no to you
right i'm looking at my website now i
haven't been on my website in ages
because i don't change it ever
so but i'll see because i i'm not sure
what it actually even says as my
headline for
empower your soul discover your purpose
live your zen life
welcome to xenogen
no
deal with horses
where's the horses in there there's no
horses in there at all
there's dirt
i can't see it you gotta bring it lower
you gotta bring it a little i see your
tv there you go yeah okay but okay but
this is the thing that could be anything
right like tony robbins might say that
and put a picture of a horse it doesn't
mean that i'm gonna actually get a horse
experience
got it it's healing with horses
or heal with horses okay
and and it's an exclusive three day in
person or three-hour online event
with horses
live
well you will learn how to
bang bang bamboo bang and if it's a if
it's a
like show me a little video of the horse
online or show me a screenshot of the
zoom people with the with dante there or
whatever
because that could be anything like
people have on if you just think about
personal development websites people
will often have sunrises and mountains
and nature scenes and horses and lions
and doesn't mean i'm gonna go pet a lion
right right so just the fact you have a
jumping horse doesn't mean i'm gonna get
i don't think i'm getting the horse
experience through this got it
because although the wording you use
just sounded personal development
well that's really
that's pretty much what it is you know
personal development coaching healing
leadership but the biggest thing that
you give is the horses
like what's your aha difference it's the
horses oh my gosh
i guess you know i've i've heard so many
things
different i get so many
50 every time the next person will tell
me don't work don't mention the horses
it's not about the horses it's about you
it's about the healing it's about the
leadership you start talking about
horses people think horseback riding
people think seabiscuit don't don't even
bring the horses up
but what are we selling
leadership and healing but through
horses right like otherwise you're just
like you're just a you're just a speaker
and then it's like why should i hire you
instead of brene brown instead of tony
robbins instead of whoever else but
you're not a little less expensive
well but
great but you're not just you don't want
to be hired just to be
a speaker it's the experience
with the horses that i'm getting
okay
it's like it's it's every time i turn
around it's someone telling me the exact
opposite you know
to do well
pick your mentor and then run like and
go and and and start and start uh yeah
you do want to what are you doing a
horse gallop gallop like pick your
mentor and gallop and go
instead of like coming back to the
starting gate and starting over each
time oh my god i can't believe you just
said that that's like that's what i
that's been the problem that's been my
number one issue is like trying to not
you know either not staying with
something long enough or st or
yeah
who says trust your instincts
you know horses horses horses i'm
looking at some of the comments
it's like yeah i i to your point it is
you know it's it's tough it's a it's a
tough zone i you know i mean i guess if
i keep saying it's tough it will be but
that's this has been my biggest
stumbling block is to try it but it's
not i don't think it's that tough to
sell i think i think it's um i think if
you didn't have the horses it'd be a
really tough sell
yeah hi i'm jen i'm a personal
development person i'm a speaker i can
help transform your culture and change
your leadership one out of a sea of
people trying to doing that or hi i'm
jen i've got my own personality test
that uh can help you figure out it's
like you're you're
you're
a giant sea of tons of people like why
should i hire you yeah that's tough
the healing with horses is
is different it's fun it's unique it's
like oh my gosh a breath of fresh air
finally the only thing is make the
connection like well how does
being around the horses what's the
experience i get that's gonna help me
get better
at leadership and communication and
self-awareness and healing and you know
whatever else you're doing
awesome but but it opens the door to
conversation where they they get on a
call with you and then they ask a
question
hey jen how do i how do we do this right
the horses becomes your you're in to
make it
different it's a reason to have a
conversation
agree
and most of the stuff they're doing is
so boring and corporate and sucks anyway
i trust that's so true
so if you're giving people an experience
that's like wow that was
how many how many people at teams are
really excited about the team building
exercise they're about to go on
right it's like if i hit another team
building exercise i'm going to leave
this team
right well and to hear the feedback you
know that you know after
after someone experiences this that the
feedback is one hundred percent i had i
i don't mind once somebody comes and
does a little taste of this you know my
conversion rate is you want to hear the
number
it's over 65 percent
so so now you need to follow up with
everybody that's that
once once they get confident and do one
thing
of almost almost two-thirds that's a
you need to like why are they not coming
back for another thing in three months
no that that's not the problem i need i
because i need more i i need more what i
really need because they do come back
but i need more of them i i don't have
enough of those i'm just at like you
said to your point um i'm back at the
starting gate again because i keep
changing what i feel like my messaging
needs to be you know and you're right
about the website i do need to make that
change um that's absolutely
i think that's going to be critical
and but healing with horses leadership
and empowerment with horses
is that's it i mean that's really what
it is and and what it does
you know you got my brain going for sure
i knew you would
because you know i i watch all your
stuff and you really do have a way to to
really shift the mindset and it's just
that little tiny thing that's going to
happen it's not that much work no
i don't have to re do my entire website
i just need to change the thing and put
healing with horses yeah like we don't
need to go build a thousand page website
this is not a giant project that's gonna
take months to finish no i agree
so the two most important takeaways from
this would be one like the the branding
and positioning of it healing with
horses the horses are front and center
and here are the benefits you're gonna
get which which you could do today you
know just update it easy yeah and then
the second part is just the the
follow-up
in the the
deal structure where we're trying to get
annual deals
and any speaking gigs are trying to come
on there every year
what is that what is a quarterly like
how do you come in and you have one
great experience and then turn that into
four experiences over the next year
absolutely and and then different
departments and referrals and referrals
and follow-ups and then a hundred
percent the question a quick question
then what what would you
think could be like a great entry offer
because i've done like the five-day
challenge thing i've done you know i've
played with a million different
entry-level things that are free excuse
me free or low cost
what you know what would you say
would be
a good because a lot of i'm still doing
a five-day challenge and i'm not sure a
challenge is the right thing
i mean where would you and that's free
and i'm i do events
once every couple i mean i'm always on
doing a something
but
where would be a good entry level based
on what you are you know
you should think what is the
having like not having experienced it
you got to think if somebody's going
through
and they're spending five days with you
what is the what is the easiest to
digest
aha because a lot of like the deeper
inner work you can't just change in a
shift in a second correct what are the
things that
create
create big ahas in a short amount of
time and that's the thing to get them to
taste like it's the appetizer like it
tastes delicious but it's not going to
fill you up
right what would that look like do you
think like well i don't know like you
got to think through your experience of
of having helped so many people
what is the appetizer to get people
into it so they they feel like wow this
is delicious i want more how do i write
more
that's you know and that we just keep
playing around and playing around with
that like trying to figure out what the
best appetizer is for it like what's the
best lead what's the best legion
experience you know you honestly may not
even need it
if you do a good job
on the other two things that we talked
about that's fair
if you fix your website in the position
and also how you talk about it like if
you if you rewind this back and and
explain how you how did you introduce
this topic to me it all started with the
four personality types of your horses
and dante and saina madanti and explain
it's like none of that matters yet like
once i'm in then that matters but to
explain what you do that stuff doesn't
matter yet
like hey i'm jen i help people heal
through the power of horses and i help
people xyz right communication skills
leadership skills right that's going to
make it a lot more
alrighty is going to
make it easier for people to understand
what you do
not fully not to like the details right
like i don't understand how the search
is going to cut the thing out of me but
i understand the results of this thing
and i'm curious to learn you do what you
heal people through horses this is crazy
yeah that's right response that i get
so it creates a conversation right which
is what we want and then two if you do a
good job with the follow-up if you think
about everybody every speaking thing
that you've done and ask them to come on
and do another one if you think about
every organization you've helped even
people who are your in-person retreat
four years ago right right and they've
all like not all but a bunch of them
moved on to other jobs a bunch of them
are still the same company that they're
at and you just followed up with
everybody and said hey
i'm doing this online program now
you'll get business yep
yep that's that's a no-brainer and um
i've i've started um
you know
re-establishing my linkedin more because
i think going to be going to
corporations going to businesses and
because when you get to go you get to
businesses you're good to individuals as
well
so
i wouldn't even worry about that yet
like that's that scale and growth and
where where it all can go but let's get
you making some good corporate money
let's get your center opened up back to
the way that you like it you know i mean
there's huge
there's huge opportunities just doing
that and you already have some momentum
and traction there like selling to
america the consumer is the hardest game
of all a million percent
yes so it doesn't mean that we can't get
there especially your mission is i want
to change the conversation around horses
and and showcase how much of a problem
this is then ultimately we need to get
to america but to go to america from the
start
is insane like
that's what i've been doing though
that's that's exactly what i've been
doing is trying to crack the crack the
big nut first
but but the path to cracking the big nut
is through the more exclusive expensive
stuff you're like tesla started with the
tesla roadster it's a six-figure car
that you bought and then they got to the
slowly making it more and more and more
affordable because what's their goal
they want to change
they want every vehicle to be electric
they want to they want to save the world
from pollution right so
but they started with the high-end stuff
they started with their niche instead of
making money like you need to start
making money yeah so that you can afford
to do all the things that you want to do
i love it
that's you know that just reinforces
what i what i've been thinking about
that like get you know just
get the get the cash flow get the flow
of money coming in through people that
understand get my get my you know early
adopters and my innovators and how many
how many people have you helped
that you actually have some kind of
email address or phone number for
probably about 6 000 emails oh my god
jen that's what that's that's all you
need to do yeah
fix the website you can do that today
don't stress about the perfect picture
and all that just change the language
around what we talked you could watch us
back we'll save it if you want
uh and then start messaging the six
thousand people
who've been through the program who who
already know how great it is because
they've witnessed it so the the
threshold to to explain it isn't there
because they already know
and then ask them how how they might be
able to bring it inside their
corporation
amazing
okay
and then you'll be filled up like if you
do a good job on the 6000 you'll be
filled up for the rest of the year
yes
you have six thousand people who've been
through your thing yeah
first they know you who like they may
not be your best friend and like follow
everything you do but no they've they've
experienced it something right they've
experienced something they know the
power of dealing with horses and so
some of them will take you right if you
just had one percent you had 60 people
take you inside the corporation to line
something up you're busy for the rest of
the year now we're looking at how do i
hire more people how do i explain
right yep i'm ready for that i'm ready
for that day that's gonna be amazing but
that's the path like don't worry about i
wouldn't even worry about your book
don't worry about the social media stuff
don't worry about somebody here
following you
you fix the website with clear
positioning based on what we talked
about and then you you reach out to the
6 000 people
get on calls with them let them know
that you're trying to get into their
their company because you want to bring
this message of healing with horses to
the world i love it you're right
60 people that would be it i would be so
busy i wouldn't know what to do
it's not the path to like crazy it
doesn't change the world yet
right like 6 000 companies at the 60
people like this doesn't change the
world yet and accomplish your mission
but it gives you the momentum and the
cash flow
to be able to then go and build the next
thing yeah yeah that's you're absolutely
right
you're absolutely right
well there that's that's you know
marching orders are in place that's easy
and everything you said is easy and i
can do any of it like that's not a
problem you're doing everything so this
yeah
this is just now more what are those
things that the horses wear the blinders
blinkers blinkers and blinders yeah
blinkers are on now jen this is
so much out no no no
well and that's and you just you just
said what you know what bellas do that's
what bellas do they're like oh shiny we
call it shiny penny syndrome you know
they have shiny penny syndrome okay you
get some of these put them on you know
or like or put them in front of your
desk or something you know it's like
that's your little virtual reminder that
okay i'm being a bella again
we're
we're stopping our own progress focus
and those things actually i think those
things are actually kind of not so those
are bad i don't like them
well
yeah the idea of them is to focus guys
right but just staying focused and and
getting that like you said you know get
get pic pick your horse
and ride it
you know
yeah and that's just it it's like my
zone of genius is the the metaphors and
the stories that i can create around
anything
that's you know yes i need focus thank
you thank you for that people in the
comments are like she's focused yeah
thanks guys
so and it's and it's so obvious when you
have a boulder in your eye right it's
tough to see around but that's really
great advice
i do yeah that's your next like that's
your next step if you do a good job with
those 6000 and you fix the messaging
and you just fix how you talk about it
yeah you'll get all the business you
need for the rest of the year
and then we can worry about scaling and
then we can worry about how you open a
center in every state and you know
across the country and how do we save a
million horses next year from being
slaughtered and how you know whatever
like the big
things are
right yeah yeah for sure
okay that's amazing thank you so much
all right
thank you jen yes thank you keep us
posted session i hope i hope everybody
that's watching got a lot out of it as
well so
thank you very much
amazing we'll see you soon thank you
take care
cheers
if you want to see me coach another
entrepreneur check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you haven't posted in a year
and now you're trying to post to all the
platforms
that could be
a huge trap i love for now stuff if you
never do for now then you get stuck of
going another year without making
content